Good morning, Hank, it's Friday.
It's actually Thursday, but tomorrow I'm going
to be in airports all day.
Now I know what you're saying, Hank: "But
John, I can tell by the gray speckled behind
you that you are currently in an airport".
That's true, but today I'm just in two airports.
Tomorrow I'm going to be in a ton of them.
Ugh boy, I am the sleepiest sleepyhead in
Sleepslvania.
Do I have the vague resemblance of a Harry
Potter scar drawn on my forehead?
No apologies.
So, Hank, today is the last day of pizzamas,
which means it is the last day that you can
buy any of these things with my mustachio-ed
face on them.
So if you want a glow-in-the-dark Pizza John
shirt or a David Bowie Pizza John shirt or
if you want to dress your baby in a Pizza
John onesie, today is the last day.
Link in the dooblydoo.
In other news, I'm very, very tired.
Cara Delevingne, Nat Wolff and I did our modeling
faces yesterday.
Hank, we've all been practicing our model
faces, Cara has a pretty good one.
It's so funny!
I can't-- it's so great!
Alright, Nat has a pretty good one.
Nat: Normal.
(everybody laughs)
John: No!
It's better when you try, it's better when
you try.
Your sincere model face.
Nat: I can't do the cheek thing.
Cara: No, you just suck it in.
John: No.. you-u-you-op..
Nat: What do I do?
John: You open your mouth a little bit...
(laughter) THAT ONE!
That one is a good one!
Nat: Was it really good?
John: No!
So this is my normal face.
And this is my model face..
like...
Nat: So subtle.
Yeah!
Cara: I like the soft attitude.
John: Hank, everyone involved in the Paper
Towns movie is doing such a great job, and
I don't know how they do it, because the hours
are incredibly long.
Like, all I'm doing is like sitting in a chair,
eating peanut M&Ms, laughing and crying, as
all these hardworking people bring this story
to life.
And yet, despite the ridiculous easiness of
my job, I am truly the most fatigued, fatigued
person in all of Fatiguedville.
So anyway, thank you to everyone in the Paper
Towns crew who's going to stay up until five
o'clock in the morning tonight, because that
is... oh boy, I don't know how you're going
to do it.
Oh, Nerdfighters, I also want to say thanks
for your feedback on Project for Awesome 2014,
I will talk more about that when I'm not the
most exhausted exhaustee in all of Exhaustia.
And Hank, I also wanted to say that I really
enjoyed Pizzamassing with you.
It's made me feel like uhh..
I don't know!
It's just been really fun.
Good ol' days kind of feeling.
You know what would also be fun, Hank?
Going to sleep!
And fortunately, I'm about to be on a giant
steel cylinder that will hurtle hundreds of
miles through the thin and unsurvivable atmosphere,
30,000 feet above sea level.
And that's just the kind of environment I'd
like to sleep in.
Oookay Hank!
I didn't really believe in myself, but I did
get some sleep on the flight, now I am in
Los Angeles.
Earlier today, I got to be with Shailene Woodley
and Ansel Elgort and lots of other people
involved in The Fault in our Stars movie.
As an Amsterdam-esque Fault in our Stars bench
was installed on the Fox lot.
The Fox lot has a statue of Napoleon Dynamite
and murals of The Simpsons and Star Wars...
and to join that kind of company is just uhh..
It's pretty wonderful.
And now, I am going to go to bed-- is what
I would like to say, but in fact, I am going
to go to the airport.
Hank, you'll see me on Tuesday.
P.S, Nerdfighters, the AFC Wimbly Womblies
have just played the most important games
in their history!
Link's in the doobly doo!
Or you can click overr...
here...